[Music]
if you could concoct a dream tornament
what would format be well with the time
control be and who would be in it I like
the classical time control I would
invite the strongest chess players
because I like to see how how the
grandmasters think and which decisions
he makes during the game
probably the same format like here but
in rapid and few classic games and also
combine some rapid and blitz games for
me ideal would be okay especially the
time control I think I'll keep it as one
and half hour for the players I would
like to have like someone really really
stronger than me
so that I can play freely and happily
yeah generally I prefer to buy more
rapid and blitz chess I think we're
pretty close to two like a perfect event
I don't know I mean we have do when June
here the reigning women's world champion
I think this field is a very good
representation of like the top women
players in the world
I like bleeds I like to play I believe
the more the stronger tournaments and
more it's interesting probably like the
standard that we use here in st. Louis
probably invite like all of the top
players you know Carlsen Cara wanna feel
my friends too we can all party together
for me I prefer faster time controls I
really enjoy repperton blitz rapid door
glitch kind of event that with a mix of
men and women players so I think that
would be more interesting to have a like
you to have a top man feels like Carlsen
Aronian everyone and to have the top
women players and probably I'll pair of
oppositely just to have fun and
entertainment with spectators
you